this is mount kilauea
hawaii's most active volcano
three years ago scientists were taken by
surprise
when lava began spewing out from cracks
in the lower slopes of kilauea
50 kilometers from the volcano's summit
the rate of should produce new lava was
almost unprecedented in historic times
so it wasn't so much the sheer size of
it it covered a very small part of the
state it was the speed with which it
didn't
in total one cubic kilometer of lava
flowed out over three months
rivers of runny lava ran down to the
ocean destroying hundreds of homes
volcanologists like bruce hauken and
matthew patrick
have been studying kilauea for decades
this is the best monitored volcano in
the world
so matthew probably wouldn't say that to
you because
yeah it would it would be a boast but
it's it's not it's the most
intensely balanced volcano and then it
had a very intense eruption
this makes kilauea the perfect volcanic
lab for studying how
eruptions happen since the 2018 eruption
the team have been piecing together the
events that triggered it
so that next time a volcano of this type
erupts
we can be better prepared
kilauea is a basaltic volcano which
means it has very fluid magma below the
surface
and tends to leak runny lava rather than
erupting explosively
at the summit there's a crater known as
hale maumau
lava has been bubbling to the surface of
halemaumau
since 2008 forming this lava lake
nearby is another crater called puo
lava has been slowly flowing out of pua
and down to the ocean
almost continuously since 1983.
to the east of puoa is an area called
the lower east rift zone
the last eruption in this zone was in
1961
after that it became a popular place to
live partly because the land here is
cheap compared with the rest of the
island but this
is where the lava flowed out in 2018
taking residents and researchers by
surprise
we had seen the pressure building at
pual and summit
and we were expecting a relatively small
change at the pua
eruption site but in 2018
for reasons that i think we still don't
fully understand that pressurization
triggered a bigger change a deeper
change
that presumably cleared a blockage that
had been restricting maglin moving
east of pua on april 30th we started to
see earthquakes
migrate east down rift so those
earthquakes migrating down rift
were a clear sign that magma was
intruding through the volcano farther
down the rift zone
it was a clear indication that something
new
and something potentially very hazardous
was was happening
on the third of may the first cracks or
fishes
appeared in the lower east rift zone
bruce rushed over there
the notion that something driven by
processes
under the summer of the volcano is going
to create something
50 kilometers away is hard to encompass
but once the fishes first formed i i was
confident that they were going to
propagate outwards you know
that you would open up one then another
then another
and what i really wanted to do was to be
around
for as many of the fish's opening as
possible
bruce used high-speed cameras to film
the gas and particles that were spat
out from the fishes first before the
lava flows got going
back in the lab by slowing the footage
down we get the size of the particles
the shape of the particles
we also can measure exactly how much is
being erupted per unit time so
the estimates of intensity come from
from those videos as well
we just measure the total amount of
material that's in the air at any second
another team analyzed the chemistry of
the lava itself
and realized that in those first weeks
it was cooler
stickier old magma coming out once that
was flushed through
they predicted that hotter more fluid
magma would arrive
from the summit magma chamber and
i remember being on one of the first
overflights after that kind of
change happened in the eruption and i
had never seen
so much lava on the surface and once we
started to see the arrival of this hot
fluid magma the hazard of the eruption
totally changed
and unfortunately it became much more
destructive
the lava covered farmland roads and
around
700 houses reaching the ocean in early
june
meanwhile at the volcano's summit
another historic event was unfolding
the crater was collapsing as magma from
the reservoir
underneath it drained away to the
eruption site
there have only been a handful of
caldera collapses that have been
monitored with
modern geophysical instrumentation what
we saw
is that the caldera collapse was not
just one big event
basically every day or so we saw the
crater floor drop several meters each
time the crater floor dropped
it caused an earthquake with a magnitude
of about 5.3
it also briefly pressurized the magma
chamber
and that sent out a pressure pulse down
towards the lower east rift zone
which caused a surge in the lava that
was flowing out there
it was really remarkable to see the
changes happening at the summit
then being transmitted basically within
minutes to produce these surges and lava
eruption rates down on the lower flank
that had direct implications for hazard
i think the biggest thing that we've
learned is
just how connected all the parts of the
system
are so a lot of people now are revising
their models for how
how you get molten rock to move not not
simply vertically
under the volcano but how you get it to
move 50 kilometers
relatively rapidly and reappear
somewhere else
um because that's the part that we have
least understanding of because it's the
part we can't see
at the moment volcanology is all about
basically simple pattern recognition
it's not about understanding
the processes the mathematics or the
physics of what's going on and that's
what we're trying to transform into